the screen rooms are for plants
yeah
I think you're the one that specified
but agreement
I mean I think it's supposed to be like
a Solarium yeah can you hear me yeah I
can hear you hello hello is it loud I
mean is it live it's live and loud loud
and Loud rolling we're rolling and
bowling ABR here we go uh-oh what's ABR
always be rolling
I can't believe you didn't know that
I don't know rule numbers like Molly or
no like rolling the camera rolling the
footage you know like I think you're in
the Hollywood yes I don't know what have
you been in I've been
um I was in Thumbelina
Thumbelina Thumbelina Thumbelina
tumbling I don't think that we're
talking about the same Thumbelina
isn't it like a thumb person like she's
the size of a thumb yeah that was me
when I was younger
yeah you were like a part of a play
no you're in a movie I was in Disney
Pixar's Thumbelina
I didn't play Thumbelina well it's a
Pixar thing so you were animated you
were the voice no I was the actual
cartoon what you're at all an acid and
you thought you were a cartoon stop
trying to make this stop trying to make
my story come through your lens
conversation
I don't know dude I wasn't I look I'm
gonna be real with you I'm not even in
the industry I started this off
immediately lying to you ABR ABR always
be Ryan oh
great amazing yeah I got that
um yeah so technically it started I
think it started let me make sure
because I'm not seeing any comments and
that's not a good sign
oh I know why it's unlisted
oh is this live yeah
I didn't know that when we did that well
why would you I never told you anything
okay I'm glad that you're aware of that
too this is for posterity everything
that we said before was like just to us
just to us and future people thank God
and now this is like live any minute now
someone should chime in something racist
to let us know that we're live uh oh
that's exciting so how do you feel about
people being racist to you I feel
horrible about it yeah online does it
make does it really hurt your feelings
no and it's something racist I'm like oh
they like me they they see me yeah who I
am what actually makes you mad well
actually don't what's the funniest
common thing that you get from these
haters
um the haters yeah what's the most
common thing that the haters say
I don't want to talk about that that
makes me sad that makes you sad yeah
I'll talk okay what do you what do you
want to talk about I didn't mean to make
you sad dude I just been dealing with a
lot of stress Liz I'm surprisers coming
from my spot I Gotta Go uncle Laser's
coming for your spot yes that's
impossible Hans no one can come for your
spot
well I'm spotting no I'm out of fear you
know what's funny I actually am spotting
does that mean you're on your period no
it means I'm I'm I I was just on my
period but like it's coming down uh it's
only a spot it's not it's just some
spots it's not a tree tree not yeah it's
not you know I don't need to use
equipment
you just let it soak yeah well I can
just pee it out
for the most part
but where does the spotting come in if
you just pee it out I mean like it's
like I wipe then I can see oh there's
some blood yeah there's spots or like I
mean maybe like a few days ago I got
some spots in my underwear right that's
where the name comes from spot spot
that's what I'm seeing I'm seeing spots
in my underwear you are and they look
like Uncle laser yeah it's like a raw
shark test
well that's [ __ ] I'm not gonna lie to
you if that's actually happening if
you're seeing it
your tattoo is like fresh that's what
everybody always says but they're just
really nice tattoos okay yeah yeah they
look like they were done in sharpie yeah
they were done with a sharpie raisin
blade super shut up [ __ ] paper clip
uh is that messed up
oh my god there actually are saying
things are they saying anything racist
though because they could just be
watching Blues Clues
that's true the only way to tell is if
they say something racist okay do you
want to read the comments that's a fun
thing we can do does it sometimes hurt
people's feelings no no yeah yeah you're
right I'm too tough
well luckily the computer is right here
are within reaching distance
wow yeah luckily you're so flexible
yeah Liz Splat this is Liz splat
this is Liz Splat this is the Splat
life's gold Splat this is a little Splat
no but right jokes dog
no bud is that like no we period blood
is best blood that's so true Elliot
Elliott
I think uh most men have developed a
taste it's an acquired taste period
blood yeah it's the most blood that we
come in contact with yeah of course
you're like a doctor yeah well still
hopefully it's the most blood that you
like put in your mouth yeah like
hopefully you don't put any other blood
in your mouth and you're like a Native
American house and you're like this was
fresh two days ago and then you taste
that you have to taste it yeah what does
type A negative oh yeah that would
that'd be crazy a superpower where you
could like figure out somebody's blood
by licking it but then you also would
get the diseases that they had yeah that
would be like blessing in a curse wow I
can feel what he was feeling with his
his age did you ever see Pushing Daisies
no oh my gosh it was this show where
like there was this guy who had super
powers or whatever and he would touch a
dead person and they'd come back to life
but if you touch them again then they're
dead forever and so if he touches a live
person he kills them
so he wears gloves yeah he has to wear
gloves and then you would have to do
that you would have to do that and he
brought this one girl back to life that
he was in love with and it gets real
crazy you can't touch her because they
can't yeah exactly you have to do some
sheet sex yeah condom sheet condom
condom Shins
I feel like my mic is quieter than yours
I feel like I just am way louder than
you and that's obvious well maybe I can
overcome that with technology I doubt it
do you know how microphones work
thank you
so this is some THC it's not CBD this is
completely illegal this is completely
illegal
come and find us
I don't care Liz do you want to like
scoot over to the left a little are you
happy where you are like this way no
like right here because I'm over here
because there's like a [ __ ] uh a gap
in between these giant pillars so I
could stick my legs through so people
watch this and they enjoy having you
like do this thing yeah it's a podcast
it's a conversation okay yeah to know us
yeah they're getting to know us we're
conversing with each other that's true I
like how I tilted it towards my side to
make myself look taller
I'm tall I'm pretty tall though I'm like
[ __ ] how how tall do you think uh me how
tall do you think I am uh just judging
by your energy I would say six one
[Music]
thank you so much Hans you have the
energy I am indeed six one no way yeah
well no that's not true
I'm not getting anything no you I
literally watched you
why do you keep blowing it out so fast
I don't want to keep it in there too
long I'll just do lots of little hits
that's my strategy why'd you say I'm not
getting anything a little immediately
most stuff out that time I got something
I don't think I got anything the other
times click the tapes we will check the
tapes
so Liz
on uh
you know I liked it better when I was
over here I'm gonna be real with you
yeah now we're at the same length same
distance from the camera uh Liz
the there's a lot going on the railroad
strikes are happening yeah what do you
think about the railroad strikes um see
your eyes literally got heavier I think
I think that I think that's bad man they
should let
they should let those trains go okay so
you don't want the railroad workers have
sick days 10 days I think is what
they're asking for no I think they
should get their sick days but I think
they should just let the trains do their
own thing okay so they just I mean you
have tracks they're they're not gonna go
yeah they're not gonna go anywhere
they're right there and then if they do
go somewhere then that's when the people
have to step in and say like
look train you got you got to go back to
where you came from you can't just be
you know on people jumping on different
tracks there's rules there's tonsils
yeah and once the you know if the trains
start to push back and they try and take
over yeah then yeah then we have to take
away the sick days and then it gets real
then you gotta get the humans involved
yeah with or whether they're sick or not
you get in the train you start coughing
let the train know you mean business oh
my God my girlfriend's calling me
one second are you answering this
it's it's a little necessary okay right
now
hi Vanessa we're live on air right now
hey guys Hans Kim here with his
girlfriend on the line
no sorry Liz spot here narrating Hans
Kim with his girlfriend on the line
Vanessa um it seems that Hans is in a
state of being stressed out about the
relationship his voice seems to have
dropped to an octave that makes me think
he is maybe a cuckold possibly
not a very good wing woman she is he is
seeming to be upset with me for some
reason however it does seem like the
conversation is taking a turn for the
better laughter is happening
maybe there are goodbyes being said
uh-oh a sudden tone drop
uh oh a goodbye has been said
and now
well I think I nailed that
yeah definitely that was fun it was like
a golf yeah it felt like Golf
and uh lining up for the shot and no he
called her an idiot
what a massage there seems to be crying
on the other end of the phone
a lot of emotional trauma and oh oh oh
and she has killed herself that is
unfortunate yikes he will be thinking
about this for the next five decades
well there we have it folks
anyways so like uh Kanye pay the workers
pay the workers yeah I mean I'm always
on the side of the workers Hans you're a
sexy beast why aren't they telling me
I'm a sexy beast is it because I put on
the shirts
it's the second I put on the shirt they
didn't they didn't they don't see me as
a maybe we need them as a woman anymore
what I mean maybe they think you're a
sexy man a sexy man yeah okay it's not
the gender I don't think Don C is
wondering what today's topic is it's me
what
[Laughter]
same thing
yeah Liz Splat how's uh how are things
they're good I mean I I applied I I
applied for a job today that's what I
was doing before this that's good to
apply yeah I know I mean I just want
like a day job
you know obviously can I be your
assistant
what could I be your assistant as my day
job
maybe yeah I'll do it I won't I won't
even need much money I just need more
money
what you need a part-time job yeah what
would you do what are you good at what
are yours I don't know you want me like
grocery shopping I can turn the I can
turn the little mop thing on downstairs
you're not even mopping you're just
turning on I know but that took a lot
from your space you know you had to do
that you could have been writing jokes
you could have been calling Rogan I
could have been doing all sorts of
things dude yeah instead of pressing a
button yeah exactly you know you press
all my buttons for it
yeah that's what I'll do
hire me part-time for something
so
um jobs are important what do you think
about
the job economy
um
I mean I I think it's not good but then
also it's good right yeah it's both it's
both because it's good if you kind of
want it if you want a job yeah but it's
not good if you want like a really good
job but then it's also bad if you need
workers but then it's pretty good if you
like want to just turn over workers yeah
but it's bad if you want Health Care
yeah well everything's bad if you want
health care right yeah yeah unless
you're born rich and white yeah are you
white yeah what do you think about the
future of the white race
um you know I think that probably we're
gonna have a pretty strong next uh 10
decades or so
yeah basically a century I think we'll
have another solid Century yeah what
happens after 21-22 well I don't think
that the next Century will be as solid
as the last one but you know I think by
the end of that I think by the end of
the century yeah there'll be like
another like race like the the white
people will be minorities in America
mid to late 20s yeah to early to late to
mid 30s but also I
I don't know like that's just like a
random guess out of what you just asked
me in this moment 100 years is good 100
I would say that's the over under yeah
it's like that's right around 50 how
much do you want to bet
[Laughter]
a hundred dollars a hundred dollars okay
a hundred dollars I bet you that what
what race do you think is gonna take
over a new one
right oh yeah
a completely new race
I think the African slash Australian
hybrids have a strong chance not only
are they I think the African Australian
uh hybrid has a strong chance of getting
in my [ __ ]
some spotted dick
because I'm Australian
wait hearken to British traditions
what so do British people have spotted
dicks that's a food
that they haven't used in Shanghai Noon
with Owen Wilson and Jackie Chan no
should I this is why white people are
gonna fall in 100 years yeah yeah no I'm
I mean like I'm I'm not one of those
white girls that like tries to get away
from being a white woman I just want
everybody to know that you know there
are like a lot of white girls that like
they're like oh well I'm also like 1 16
Portuguese or whatever yeah you know I'm
just like look I'm from Dallas and I'm
white you're white and that's the
situation at hand yeah I could go and
find my lineage and claim different nut
wool I have a hunch
but I don't know it's not like it's not
I'm still White
you know I'm American
yeah in my outs like I feel American
yeah the Neapolitan mix you're the uh
yeah but I don't like strawberry ice
cream yeah [ __ ] the Native Americans
what
strawberries bold of you to think that
Native Americans were strawberry I would
think Hispanics are strawberry whoa why
because they pick it dude
you are what you pick that
that's not true
yeah or else Nick Fuentes would be a
booger
Nick Fuentes would be a booger yeah is
that a guy picked his nose yes he's like
a grouper he's like a Ultra right-wing
uh like irony bro that's like low-key
anti-semitic and racist Hans what do you
do like
like what are you in the morning like
you get up and then what
I lay around try to get my neck to feel
good and then I listen to some hassanabi
listen to some Chapo Trap House listen
to some
not just bikes you know not just bikes
yeah is that a band no it's a YouTube
channel about public transit and City
infrastructure
okay
that's a that's a podcast you listen to
It's a YouTube channel yeah it's all
about diversifying your transportation
options
you listen to that every day
how did you learn about what what do you
what do you use to intake news
Chapo Trap House what is Chapo trap
house
my famous friends uh Chapo trap house is
a dirtbag leftist podcast about
uh you know having
uh hope in uh making positive changes
societally instead of just being like
it's impossible it's like no this is the
things that you have to do to run a good
society and then like being like
ruthlessly cruel to people what would
your Society be named if you could
create your own Society not physically
my society would be called the
hansitarians positarians yeah nice and
we would all
right every day everyone wake up right
yeah you don't have to wake up at the
same time but eventually you have to
write and then you have to go on stage
and everyone needs to talk to each other
and communicate and then we'll get
really good at communicating with each
other and then we just have to figure
out what to do after that yeah what
about like food do you think you'd
figure out food before the stage thing
Joe Biden can figure out food I think I
can yeah you could figure it out all you
have to do if you're the president and
you just want to go par for the course
you just have to be like uh everyone
keep on keeping on
and just signed like yeah like here's
like 500 for cheetahs every now and then
nice shake some hands you would would
that be your charity that you would give
to First cheetahs
yeah it's just like not it might be dogs
nobody's gonna be offended except for
like farmers in South America or like
Africa yeah or maybe like gazelles yeah
because ours would be horribly offended
yeah that's like their Boogeyman yeah
seriously like the really fast real
boogeyman yeah I would hate for a
cheetah to chase me
yeah oh my God that was not a good
Hunter they're not doing that well but
they would probably jump on you I don't
even like when my cat jumps on me
sorry my ear itches guys
well that's good podcasting yeah it's
just real
it's Cinema very it's podcast verite so
yeah I mean cheetahs are out there
they're very fragile their strategy is a
little interesting why what do you think
about uh society and how can we fix the
mess that we're in do you even admit
that there's a mess do I admit it yeah
I'll admit it yeah
I'll admit there's a mess
I mean it's it's everywhere right isn't
the mess
bigger than anything we could possibly
imagine I don't know like what do you
mean how do I fix Society I can't fix
Society I mean all I can do is make my
is do my thing be mine be the difference
what if your thing is the fixing Society
my thing isn't fixing Society my thing
is being as good of a person as I can be
to imagine for once okay okay let's see
um if I could fix Society
you know
I would make sure that toll roads toll
roads don't cost money I don't get that
then they'd just be roads yeah just more
roads just make the roads those are
roads those are small roads roads again
make roads yeah exactly Untold roads and
um you know
I would probably
are you mad at me I'm listening am I mad
at you yeah no I'm not mad at you
yeah well I was trying to I was trying
to think about how to save Society by
your request that's important and then
you were yeah of course and then you
attacked you just started laughing
apparently my house is done being
cleaned by the Roomba that was quick
usually it takes like two hours that's
what you were looking at while I was
trying to figure out how to heal a
society you were laughing you just
busted up packed away at your Roomba
notification I laughed at your reaction
to me checking my phone no it felt like
you immediately Italian mobster what is
this guy doing
what are you doing buddy
you're just like so you weren't even a
fat you were just like noticing like oh
my God look at this [ __ ]
that's so funny that's exactly what I
was doing yeah like I'm not gonna talk
I'm not even gonna finish a sentence
yeah no honestly
um I would say that
first thing first I would uh of the
realest yeah
drop this and let the whole world feel
it and then so when to murder business I
can hold you down like I'm giving
lessons to physics right right you know
one time I got arrested uh and either
way yeah and I uh was driving on the
highway trying to find the Iggy Azalea
freestyle that really sucked and I was I
got distracted I was driving too fast
and then I got pulled over with weed on
me and so I got arrested
yeah that sticky Iggy sticky Iggy yeah
that's the truth yo when I was from
Australia when I was in high school I
idolized her
why because she was a thick white girl
who had like was she thick yeah she has
like a really fat ass I was too busy
listening to her music yeah she was like
a really big ass good for her yeah good
for her yeah you know oh yeah girl it's
something so disgusting about like
pretending to talk not normal I want to
read these again
well as long as you're having fun I'm
baffled Hans an answer to that question
holy
is Hans we gay anyone else at work
killing time oh it's not the music it's
not music Chapo that is oh Chapo isn't
music it's not like trapo
trapo music oh yeah
yeah I didn't know
I didn't know any of those things that
you were talking about earlier but I
found out that they're all YouTube
channels in ways that you get
information yeah mostly on YouTube what
do you do for news you just tune it out
and just hear from the Grapevine and
whatever your reactionary uncle takes
you yeah
essentially what's the latest news story
to really get your emotions
um the latest news story to really get
my emotions
I mean
I can't think of anything
I remember when a while ago Nancy Pelosi
got like
her [ __ ] rocked or her husband's [ __ ]
right well how did that make you feel I
was like damn
why they go after Nancy like that
not my girl yeah not my girl bro yo my
Nancy yo not my girl's man bro
don't go after my girl Nancy or I might
have to get fancy and go try to figure
out how to go panty and you better have
a plan B oh [ __ ]
thank you thank you
thank you so Nancy Pelosi I feel like a
lot of people were like
you know Anderson Mill Pub have you ever
been there yeah
did you hear what happened at Anderson
Mill Pub No some dude uh a boyfriend or
an ex-boyfriend or one of the bartenders
came in had a gun
it's like can we talk she said no he was
like well what do you want to talk now
and then two guys reached it got three
shots off boom I like try to shoot like
this boom
and then to try to shoot himself but
yeah it happened in Anderson Mill Pub
there's a video of it are they are
people okay no one got shot everyone's
okay good yeah wow but yeah that
happened in Anderson Anderson Mill Pub
open mics everything
is it oh I think it is yeah wow wait was
that this past Tuesday no that was on
Saturday or Friday or something what oh
dude that just goes to show don't break
up with your abusive ex he will come to
your job with a gun don't do it just
stay with us stay with him stay strong
stay strong because think about the
regulars at your bar job yeah think
about other people for once
abused people are kind of selfish
yeah they're like oh my eye is black
like what about
one of your husband's fist yeah it's
black
whoa are you saying no it's black and he
suffered more so yeah and you know you
should take his reparations yeah
you you only have a black eye he has a
he has everything everything's black oh
my God no I mean I don't think black
people he was white so yeah I know that
guy Anderson Mill sounded like a [ __ ]
white guy
yep that's some white ass Behavior
that's the truth going to Anderson Mill
inside
a bar in a strip mall
and shooting nothing yeah
yeah missing shots sounds like a white
guy
ah
this is a
I already commented on the room oh [ __ ]
I forgot to turn this off
oh dang now we're cooking now I'm really
lit lit yeah AF there isn't a shadow
anywhere above the table
hey
um
Hans what what's your
what's your favorite sport to watch UFC
MMA
oh yeah you've been going to those games
have you always been this yeah I mean
I've been a fan of it since uh I heard
it I heard you know everyone talking
about it mostly Joe Rogan like nine
years ago 10 years ago so yeah I've been
watching it for a consistently long time
you think I should get into that no you
don't think I should fight no why it's a
it's not a good way to use your body or
your energy as a human being why what's
the best way to work out in your opinion
uh I would say build Bridges or like do
direct actions and like to work out
change
to work out oh yeah what's the best way
to work out oh yeah that's a good way to
work out it's a little aggressive I mean
it'll make you look at people as
punching bags I think maybe a better way
to work out would be to like start
lifting yeah I've been thinking about
lifting do you think I could you think I
should go get into like a like a swole
girl phase like power lifting
I think that would be great yeah you
think do you want that for me or do you
not want it I do yeah I think that would
be great I think uh you could be like
that girl from Encanto okay I'm gonna
ask you a lot of things and I'm gonna
see if you do want that for me if you
don't want that for me okay do you or do
you not want that from me with Liz Splat
okay and Hans and Hans Kim okay
um okay
I getting married in the next five years
do you want that for me or do you not
want that for me I want that you want
that for me why do you want me to get
married the next five years I'm 25. 5
30. that's a good time by 30. yeah women
start falling apart at 27. Jesus Christ
okay well I'm just kidding no I think
everyone should get married I think it's
a better system and the way that we have
it now like most people are primed for
that yeah okay that's the way we go okay
um let's see
okay should I do I'm having a hard time
thinking of anything
um that I I wonder if you want for me
that shouldn't be new for you what I'm
saying that you're not really like
thinking about me or other people
what why did you wait till like so long
on to just make this like weird insole
at me I'm sorry I didn't mean to say
that uh what I meant was I don't even
think that you I'm glad that uh you want
to get married
um I never said I want to get married
Mass
whatever
I'm not really
present
what do you do you want to do you enjoy
doing this no yes
what why'd you say
same old I was just trying to figure out
what response would get what reaction
gotcha
um yeah do you want to maybe buy a car
do you have a car I have a car maybe
move out of Texas do you want to move
out of Texas anytime soon no
five years nah move officially yeah
maybe nah I'd probably stay here I don't
know
well all over everywhere
oh I'll probably be all over there
yeah all over everywhere all at once oh
my God that was the movie like
everything everywhere all at once yeah
like the movie that you probably loved
right the people that look like yeah
they kind of look like you yeah that
movie was crazy I watched it on an
airplane
I wasn't a big fan of it it was kind of
crazy it was like crazy Asians crazy
poor I never saw that yeah it was like
crazy poor Asians yeah because they're
definitely mentally going through a
breakdown yeah seeing things definitely
so they're crazy they're poor it kind of
reminded me of Scott Pilgrim Vs the
World do you remember that
yes I love that movie that was a good
movie that was a really good movie but
because the story was just the story of
this guy this was like the story of like
it was a generation and
time travel and like like haunted people
and stuff like it's like weird I just
didn't like how it was so did you ever
see twitched
no
you guys gotta let them know twitch
twitch with Mia and uh Tia Tamara
wait yeah Tia and Tamara yeah it was so
crazy dude they were like twins and they
were like witches and they had to fight
this one guy to get their old witch
family back together
what's your favorite movie of all time
Fight Club my favorite movie of all time
is Cat in the Hat the live action
picture with uh Jim Carrey no with Mike
Myers yeah with Mike Myers that's the
Grinch that you're thinking about though
that's also a great Dr Seuss so you like
fantastical
weirdo like sort of like Dr Seuss
animals with like little horns and beaks
yeah I like weird stuff like that for
sure
like Shrek I love Shrek yeah yeah that's
like the same look
is like claymation or whatever yeah I'm
down for claymation so would you do you
see a Fantastical world and you're like
you look around and you see people as
like these
like yeah caricatures yeah you
definitely are a caricature to me what's
the most defining feature of my
caricature
um huge [ __ ]
thanks
okay let's wrap it up
needed
[Laughter]
I'm just trying to get invited back you
know what I'm saying
I thought you're gonna say chin no okay
let me think if your character to me
it's probably just your head in general
you have this very defined head you know
yeah it's a good silhouette yeah it's
yeah exactly it's a yeah it totally is a
logo just mouth a gape watching an open
mic yeah yeah like
or sometimes a lot of times you look
like this
I don't know it just looks like you to
me no it's like you're like smiling but
you're for that's somehow like you're
you're smiling but you're also like
like you're like zoned out face like
most people's zoned out faces like but
yours is like
[Laughter]
that's a general yeah General Pleasant
Haze that's what I think about Pete
Davidson Pleasant Haze yeah he's just
like a pleasant Cloud over here yeah
girls like it like oh look
I don't know I think that girls project
onto Pete Davidson and yeah he's an
empty canvas exactly okay yeah yeah he
is whatever you need him to be that's so
true he's like the room of requirements
is the deck of requirement he is the
dick of requirement
I would yeah
I wouldn't mind being the [ __ ] of
requirement for like a year or two yeah
you find a [ __ ] broom closet in there
and a yeah
okay Canary yeah and a canary and
you know never ending stickers I mean
don't you think that uh we all want to
be something to somebody like we want to
be of course everyone's requirement room
of requirement
um
we all want to be everyone's room of
requirement or somebody's remember like
at least one yeah we want to be
somebody's everything yeah yeah for sure
I think that's why a lot of people have
kids
next to Parkway out texting me why why
do you keep note mentioning these tiny
tiny little that's almost more
insignificant than the Roomba
oh my God
Nick she says you're less than a Roomba
but you can actually vacuum up and and
like one liners yeah
and tell one-liners
did that do anything I love this note
that somebody said
Liz reminds me of my loud bisexual
chubby ex with depression and abusive
ex-boyfriends
I don't understand it's getting worse
and worse
Okay so
I have like a big chance
oh uh Nick's apaglia Roomba
um
what do you think about
socialism
is this what your podcast is yeah this
is so different than every other podcast
actually can you explain socialism to me
so explain to me like I'm five
is where
things like factories
are
were decisions made in factories are
decided by everybody
and not just for the enrichment of one
person but for the good of everybody
okay then what's
being a libertarian
a Libertarian is like do the factory one
again what happens in the factory if
it's a Libertarian Factory it's just
like one guy is like I own it I get to
do whatever I want if you don't like it
you can [ __ ] off I'm gonna make your own
Factory yeah I think I like that more
you know like multiple people I don't
think I think that sounds really messy
is it not gonna be messy like can't you
vote online what if you can vote I guess
you could vote online will it get hacked
the thing is pretty easy if it's one guy
that runs it then he's gonna do whatever
is in his best interest and that might
hurt lots of people that's true but then
in libertarian can't can't they just go
and make their own Factory or is it
that's on a lot because everybody at the
fact at the original factories like no
this is my stuff I'm not gonna give you
my stuff well go make your own Factory I
mean it's not easy to make a factory in
like the land and like maybe they could
like out compete you like if they're a
big business they could charge like nine
cents a profit do you want me to be a
socialist yes okay I'll think about it
what can you give me another argument
for a different stance just so I can
feel like you're not just trying to get
me to be a socialist
um I mean democracy my friends are
communism Communists what about that
that's like the same socialism to the
max right yeah it's like
like since we can't do anything anyways
I might as well take a be or identify
myself as a word that will shock you so
that you have to like be like oh [ __ ]
things yeah things are correct or
something's weird yeah but yeah I mean
it's just it's like these words that we
put on it's like how should we organize
society and should we have maybe more
Sweden or more America right now like
should we go more money in profit and
greed or should we go more like
Universal Health Care and like niceness
and around the edges like you don't want
to get too you don't want to Nerf the
whole world but you don't also want to
make it like Mad Max and just like
everyone's in it for themselves because
yeah you definitely yeah you don't want
to know if the whole world
right yes you don't want to do that yeah
that'd be a bad idea but if we could
yeah you wouldn't do it rule the whole
world Nerf the whole world Nerf the
whole world rounded edges like no stairs
what if I press this right now and
there's a red button and I was like this
will end everything you tell me you
wouldn't everything kind of press it
well Nerf I met with by nerfing I meant
like softness you know like how soft it
is oh I meant like hit it with a Nerf
ball gun
just bounces off then
okay yeah you're right fine I'm a
socialist
well what do you think about Elon Musk
and Twitter Elon Musk buying Twitter yes
okay
um Elon Musk buying Twitter I mean
I like Twitter the way it was I don't I
don't get what elon's gonna do I
definitely don't like like buying
verifications but then it's also like
wait that makes me wonder how were
people getting verifications beforehand
you know yeah it was all like you got to
know somebody
and if you have an agent they'll help
you yeah yeah exactly and so now it's
like okay well what does
what does it mean now it kind of It kind
of rocked my world a little bit because
I'm like oh this thing that I kind of
held as some sort of value now I'm like
wait what was that what was that value
again why did I value that well it seems
like the first week or two was really
crazy but now there's not a lot of news
coming out it's been like a week or two
where there's he's not [ __ ] up
horribly I mean like I know about it I
don't know I I always hear like crazy
things about Elon and obviously like
he's a pretty crazy guy online but like
it seems like he's been running Tesla
pretty successfully for a long time
right and like
he does he does stuff he hasn't seemed
to get arrested or like you know have a
lot of drama go on other than it was
weird that he dated Grimes but it
doesn't seem like he's the most unhinged
person alive yeah it's just I think he
could run Twitter he shouldn't be our
only person deciding what to do we
should all have a say and that's too
much pressure for this one crazy guy too
much pressure for that one crazy guy and
he's so pale and built so weird he's not
gonna survive
he can't survive on Twitter I mean I'm
just gonna go on Twitter and roast him
and then I'll just you know he'll
evaporate I'm gonna tweet him
I'm going to Tweet Elon what should I
say to him Elon more like
be
I'm gonna say
Elon
we're coming for you
[Laughter]
that's we're coming we're gonna get me
band too we're coming I'm just gonna say
we're coming not coming for you
everybody's coming we're coming having
fun I'm not gonna tag you but here's
it's just gonna be a picture of you it's
fine you can tag me no it's too late so
what do you think about uh thanks for
letting me tag you bro what do you think
about the Austin comedy scene oh my god
dude it's like
the best what are you doing tonight
tonight
I'm not doing anything tonight
but I'm on shows the rest of the week
what are you doing this week
um can I look because I forgot the names
what are you looking forward to
um oh yeah tomorrow I'm at East Austin
comedy club which is like one of my
favorite clubs in this in the city
because it's like such a good room yeah
I love it it's pretty it's red you're
there tonight yeah can I have your spot
nope okay I tried
and um also tomorrow I'm getting my car
windshield fixed which is big for me
it's not common that's not the Austin
comedy scene wow
um and then the next night I'm at
Velveeta on the second what's wrong with
your windshield
um a piece of wood fell off from an
18-wheeler when I was on the road and it
hit my windshield and it cracked it real
bad did you were you in the car yeah I
was in the car and you know what's crazy
okay okay so I had just driven from
Dallas and literally I had driven from
Discount Tire when I left because my
tire was flat when I when I like left my
show and then before that in Austin my
tire was flat and like the weekend
before that in Houston my back
windshield got busted into and they
stole my Mac so I've had like a lot of
crazy car stuff
yeah that's the thing about cars venmo
at covered in Liz cash app dollar sign
covered in Liz sorry continue that's the
thing about cars is like you have to
keep maintenance yeah it's not just the
gas it's not just the licensing we're
getting the oil change it's such a big
old thing that you gotta lug around this
exoskeleton that you need I know do
anything
it's so scary to have a car I'd like to
break it or whatever yeah that's crazy
so you were I mean 18 wheelers on the
highway next to sedans I I'm not a big
fan of that and I think it's like Amazon
and Walmart that are using our public
highways because they don't have to pay
for that [ __ ] we are okay for that hunts
before you even get into whatever the
[ __ ] this is about to be let me just
tell you that it was an individually
owned tow truck that was actually that
was actually Wheeling stuff extremely
illegally with one of those like did you
have you ever seen those dude I got the
license plate number and I got the
little side number on the thing but they
were like I submitted a claim with the
insurance and they were like that's not
us we literally don't even have wood on
our trucks and like we're not from here
and I was like what you don't have a
dash cam no I don't have a dash cam
I have one on my moped well good if that
ever happens to you on your moped you'd
probably die anyway
that's true yeah that's scary yeah I
mean that's crazy like I bet like they
just placed it they're like hey we're
gonna move this and they place it and
they forgot about and they took off dude
here's the thing this is what it was so
like you know those like they're like
dumpster trucks where like you can like
throw wood in them and then they have
like a thing that's supposed to like
roll over and be like a lid you know
have you ever seen those and then like
it's rolled up but it can like roll out
like toilet paper you know what I'm
talking about yes
but that thing wasn't even rolled out
like it was just like told like things
were just like flying from the top of
this [ __ ] truck it was crazy yeah and
I saw like one thing driving I was like
right and then I was like and then it
just hit me and it was like dude [ __ ] I
hate
I hate driving
is very nobody ever talks about that
nobody talks about how stressful driving
can be just you know not just bikes does
uh
I don't understand you Hans and I but I
just really do like appreciate whenever
we have one-on-one time it's it it's
like I don't understand you but whenever
we're one-on-one I do get you you know
what I mean what happens when we're not
having a one-on-one what do you think
about when I think about you
conceptually
I'm like what the [ __ ] why because like
you're listening to like this like bike
show and then you're like you like
where'd you get all these lights and
like you know like it's just like you're
just this like you're at with your like
weird ideas of putting like cameras on
the door it's like it's like it's I'm
not hating it's obviously working for
you it's just like you're an interesting
guy
are you denying this I can't be saying
new information to you I mean why are
they going to the windows
why are the wires going to the windows
these are the lights it goes in from
here oh cool
yeah no I mean you're definitely weird
Hans wait what are you talking about
do you not get what I'm saying
um yeah you're like wow what is it and
you have that little thing that you puff
up with your neck to get your neck it's
like it's like it all makes sense but
like
it's like an interesting weird well guy
well yeah I think the defining factor in
all these things that you've noticed
about me is that I don't try to be cool
like cool yeah something that I yeah
you're just being you dude from totally
do you think I'm like that or do you
think I'm trying to be cool no but I
don't think you define yourself in terms
of your opposition to cool I have an
idea of very much your own person and
your force of Nature and you're like a
big presence and you're like you're not
going to be contained by any Notions
like just ideas [ __ ] yeah I can't be
turned you're like Hannah Fontana yeah
I'm like Anna son wait Santana
well you're a Mexican yeah
I'm like um
Cantina yeah I'm like Hannah
banana
also Liz you're killing it on stage this
is super polite foreplay I'd watch him
came counts Kim talk anytime I'd like it
when litz Liz toots
her flute
oh
Hans Kim is a trip
why don't you like when I read them
because I just they're not here they're
not present
it's just but you
asked me you said this is a fun thing
that people do sometimes yeah but it's
like a thing that we should do and then
not do but like it's something no racism
yet I know oh it's sometimes like a
black hole Yeah it's just like
they're watching us and we're watching
them and it's like a mirror facing each
other oh yeah there's no content being
created so you've already gone yeah
you've gone down this does it happen to
everybody when they see the comments it
is a thing that happens
okay I also feel like I have to do that
I feel like that's my role because it's
like otherwise yeah I don't want to look
at the thing the whole time I'd rather
totally be in the room these people are
great and we need them but they are
limited in how much like sometimes they
have great comments but yeah it's like
this is it's not really about them
yeah it's about me yeah it's about us
it's about me yeah
it's about our Dynamic together
so Hans how long do you think you'll
stay on KT
let's get to the real questions till how
much do you get paid in those arenas
sorry I was just trying to ask like as
many like questions that were just a
little too personal but I am I am
curious about the KT thing
I mean I guess until Uncle laser comes
yeah let's hope that that doesn't happen
yeah I know for sure obviously
um but yeah until
I mean I haven't even I don't think like
I'm I want to figure it out I don't want
to get good at it yeah I mean so I want
to do that and then maybe if I do that
and then it's boring for me but I mean
it's definitely not so yeah totally
I want to keep doing it I don't know
it's like
yeah it's like I don't know aren't you
wondering how long I'll do my internet
series what is that it's called rules
for things with Colton Jones it's on my
Instagram who's Colton Jones that's my
roommate and my best friend I don't know
Colton you don't know Colton calm
Downing no Colton Jones
he's the best you would like Colton for
sure what does he do he's a comic and an
actor what how have I not seen him
before well he's from Dallas originally
and then he recently moved out here
maybe like four months ago three months
ago
what uh what's his Essence his essence
like very
um in control of the room you know like
he's the kind of person that you would
like like you'll kind of like look at
them when they walk in a room but
um you know he's just natural he's just
gonna be himself at all times he's also
like when I'm saying this and I'm a loud
person like he's so loud oh like he can
be loud he's not pipes he has more
control over it than I have
you know like I get I get out of my head
and I started screaming yeah I get
really excited and I get but Colton I
think he gets he has a more I mean he's
a man so he can he can rate he can rage
in his emotions a little more
statistically he can he can deaden yeah
he can dance emotion so they exactly
commit Genesis he can feel a more
embarrassment naturally than I can
uh well yeah that sounds like a great
loud person yeah yeah we have a thing
online and I think we'll do it probably
until I think it's boring as well
that sounds so mean
yeah I'm bored it's not boring I gotta
go do something else now yeah
it'd be like that dude yeah I've walked
away from podcasts because of that yeah
I mean you gotta follow your points yeah
exactly otherwise you might as well just
have an office job yeah no I quit my
office job recently
um because of that it was too boring
yeah you did something I was like I
can't even do this during the day job
dude it's too boring yeah yeah
well yeah don't do it that ends your
mind that's where you get Alzheimer's
and Dementia I thought Benadryl was how
you got dementia nope that's what Colton
told me
is he wrong did he say it loudly yeah
then he was probably right was he a man
yeah and he's white
what what
gosh so that's cool you quit your job I
think we're all having a quit demic
we're all quitting our jobs we're all
saying [ __ ] you to the employers we have
power we have demands what is one demand
that you have for your next job
I want to work as little as possible oh
so you want a job that requires minimal
minimal work yeah I don't I don't want
to do much of the jobbing little job I
want a job that lets me get paid
to be funny and cool and I so I can and
I can write comedy during the day
okay and honestly I think I found I
think I found the one
what is it I'm gonna work at a smoke
shop a local Austin smoke shop
that's cool I know dude I'm excited
hello I know I'm like hi how do you want
a bomb that's gonna be me really how
long do you think that that'll last
before you're like I'm bored every other
smoke shop employee like what are you
buying buddy hey hurry up we don't have
all day
foreign
how long do I think it'll last before I
become an Indian guy
an idiot man yeah months
collecting withhold for months what do
you think is the uh the weak Link in the
uh you know like what do you think will
get to you first in terms of like
dealing with customers
um I I don't want people to be weird to
me and to say weird things to me yo this
this looks like a kind of place where
like I could go snorkeling I'd be like
and I'd run away
I'm terrified
um well yeah I mean uh I would hate to
work at a smoke shop where was your last
day job like where was it Sushi sending
in on 33rd Street in New York City
Manhattan I think it was 33rd Street or
37th or something Sushi zinyin said then
is it good
yeah uh they really had you do that yes
what Hiroshima said how many people in
your party right this way please what
does that mean it means like welcome or
something or like prepare for sushi whoa
did you see that Curb Your Enthusiasm
episode no
have you seen the new season of Kirby
right there oh my God Hans well can you
complete your thought yeah well you know
there was an episode where basically he
goes into like a sushi place and they're
like harassment and then
um and then he says it back to them and
then he like his guest comes in that he
was gonna meet for breakfast dinner or
whatever and he Larry David says
before the restaurant guys can and um
the restaurant guys come up to him and
they're like hey you can't say that
that's our thing yeah and he's like I
can't say Hiroshima say
how do you say it it's an eye like
it's almost Irish but
I don't know I don't know if that's
right that's how I said it and I got
away with it for months
so uh why so what do you think I mean I
think David Larry David is being a
little disrespectful he doesn't really
know what it means so like why is he
saying it yeah no I mean
I mean they were making but I think the
point that he was making was come on you
know what I mean I think he makes a good
point The Vibes he's ruining the Vibes
yeah he's like look at this this is just
a joke we can just like
mock them and they just have to make our
food for us
see
I didn't look at it like that
yeah you're right
I mean I think you're right we should
cancel Larry David well what was his
reasoning I mean I literally I think his
reasoning was him being like I can't say
it who cares
but then later on like they totally got
him back because they basically stole
his umbrella from him it was a whole
thing that's it was really funny it's a
good he was pissed good trade-off of it
yeah
so uh what do you think about uh all
that Japanese Asians what is your
opinions on Asians
uh I mean you're cool thanks
but
you know I've never I've never been with
an Asian guy or a girl not even on like
a field trip
I've never been in the same room as one
oh well
until today obviously not true
no
um I mean I'm cool with all Asians I
think all the Asian food is bomb as [ __ ]
um
yeah
balut yeah what's that it's egg that's
fertilized and it's like about to turn
into a chicken but not yet
and then just like
[ __ ] it ferment it and then it's like
you can see a little chicken in there
and then you like eat it and you can
feel the bone the the beak the crunchy
beak
did you eat that no
okay yeah then not that everything but
that well and heathens you know some
rumored Asian food maybe not that great
but like bats yeah or cats Penguins yeah
whatever dogs whatever isn't typical
meat that I would normally eat
and like you know like I'm not even
really against the concept of like
eating cats and dogs and stuff because
like you know if they're out there but
like I hear that they like abuse the
[ __ ] out of them and stuff like there's
like a whole festival of like abusing
the [ __ ] out of animals so that they
like taste better and stuff I saw that
on the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
so you can't tell me that's not true
Beverly Hills yeah they did a donation I
think that maybe it's propaganda
to other eyes to otherwise you really
think it is Beverly Hills The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills do you think
that they had a propaganda to otherwise
the Asian people yeah in Taiwan Taiwan I
think it was I think they were like
they're weird they're different oh my
God that is so weird I'm so glad I'm
here we don't have to think about
anything else but this narrow little
world that we're living in because
everywhere else is a dog torturing
Festival is that true is that what I
have description of being Asian no
obviously I'm not asking you if that's
true as far as like everywhere in Asia
being a doctoring thing but I'm saying I
was under the impression there
legitimately was at least one
yeah microprocessors no yeah ultimately
I think what Asia has way more than well
in a day-to-day Foods uh that you know
are my pets is aren't they like
technology King
yeah yeah
trains talk about trains what do the
bikes guys say about that those guys
they love it they love Asia right the
investment they're like we're gonna do
this they're all connected you don't
know I wish there were more trains out
here dude yeah it's the perfect place
for trains yeah miles of nothing yeah no
tunnels no mountains just [ __ ] shoot
us right through it with a [ __ ] train
it would be perfect why don't you get
why don't you get on building some of
those Hans because the people don't want
it the people don't want trains for real
oh yeah why not because they're too
admired into their car brain culture of
just being like this is the only way
yeah that's so rough because like when I
went when I was in Chicago when I
visited my friend we were just like
taking trains and buses and it was so
nice dude yeah because you can have a
continuous flow yeah and also no matter
where you are you're never abandoned
yeah
you can always be like I'm uh I'm gonna
head out like everyone is like
independent like everyone can yeah on
their own exactly get a ride exactly
that'd be perfect
can we um
can we like start that change in the
world
what do you think is going to happen
first there's a train from Dallas to
Houston to San Antonio Austin or that
we're going to legalize weed here first
weed
you think so I think so that's just a
struggle of a pen yeah
and like when they're so [ __ ] close
why is it not happening
I mean I heard it because of you
I mean they're afraid everyone will turn
into me
definitely all of us are afraid of that
constantly but
no I mean why isn't it happening I don't
know dude I'm a [ __ ] cancer survivor
so like I want weed legalized hardcore
yeah yeah like it was like the best
thing medically
for me yeah yeah
that's awesome it's like really [ __ ]
that it's not medically legal actually
yeah
blanket yeah everything else that they
were giving me was like knocking me out
I couldn't eat you know it's like
unnatural it's like hit you from like a
tweak something yeah exactly the wheat
is just like a general overall yeah gets
everything yeah just like get you know
get zooted and then like watching
SpongeBob
well do you want to wrap it up
no I'm just kidding I have to go to uh
no yeah of course we can wrap it up Hans
it's your podcast we did an hour yeah
this was a lot of fun thanks for coming
I'm sorry that it was
you were like kind of nervous in the
beginning
um I was nervous
I mean you were kind of like
but we didn't know what's happening and
you're like oh yeah I didn't know what
was happening actually